The superhero genre has seen its fair share of Tinseltown a listers come and go here's why some of the biggest names
Abandoned their most super heroic roles heads up some spoilers ahead over the years Hugh Jackman has appeared as the internally conflicted
Wolverine a whopping nine times but his ownership of the role was clear the first time he donned the claws for x-men at this point
It's almost impossible to imagine another actor in the role
But unless there's a dramatic turn of events
It seems that's just what we'll have to do prior to suiting up for Logan
Jackman announced that his ninth appearance as Wolverine would ultimately be his last according to People magazine
Believe it or not a chat with Jerry Seinfeld
About his decision to finally leave Seinfeld had a hand in Jackman's decision to walk away from the character here
He said look when you're creating something. It's very important not to run yourself dry
It's not about finishing on top necessarily but making sure that you're creatively still got something left
Jackman says he decided that same day to make Logan his final film as Wolverine
Luckily, he left with a bang. The film was a massive critical and box office success and serves as a fitting final chapter
Christopher Nolan's The Dark Knight made Christian Bale the definitive Batman for many fans of the character after Nolan walked away
Warner Brothers was desperate to keep Vale on board according to Business Insider prior to announcing Batman vs
Superman dawn of Justice Warner Brothers reportedly offered bail as much as 50 million dollars to Don the Cape for director Zack Snyder
but Bale
It seems had seen enough of life in the Batcave because he turned down the loot and retired his bat suit for good
Nolan choosing not to return to the franchise was a big part of his decision
According to screen crush Bale has always maintained that he and Nolan already told the Batman story
They wanted to tell but he also said he wouldn't say no if Nolan came to him with a new Batman script
Michael Keaton also turned down a stack of Benjamin's and walked away from playing Batman in Batman Forever back in 1995
That move came a full 6 years after he first donned the cape for Tim Burton in the Venge onra defining film Batman
The film proved a massive with fans and a financial juggernaut at the box office as did the pair's deliciously
Divisive follow-up Batman Returns, though Keaton didn't immediately exit Batman forever
He certainly began to rethink his involvement once Burton wasn't on board
Apparently he knew he was done after he read the rewritten script in Keaton's own words
Yeah
There you go
Keaton felt so passionately that he reportedly turned down a fifteen million dollar payday to reprise the role
It's been a bumpy road to respectability for Marvel's tortured bad-boy
Vigilante Frank Castle that road took an interesting turn in 2004 when a big-screen version of The Punisher got the green light
Sadly the excitement faded fast. Once the film was released to put it mildly the film with a critical and commercial failure
but Thomas Jane's ability to bring the right mix of malice and
Melodrama was enough for the studio to sign him up for the planned sequel Punisher war zone
But according to antique cool news Jane left the project
Just prior to cameras rolling because he felt the sequel script was quote
Too comic book and didn't give Frank Castle the treatment he deserved if you're wondering what happened to that film
It was released in 2008 and met with just as much critical and commercial strife as the original history
It seems as proven Thomas Jane, right?
Hugh Jackman isn't the only member of the Logan cast that decided to ride off into the sunset after Wolverines last stand Patrick Stewart
Professor X himself also
Announced his departure from the x-men universe prior to Logan's release according to Entertainment Weekly
if you've seen Logan already the news that Stewart is out will come as no surprise since the character meets his own end in the
Film of course death hasn't stopped Professor X from returning to the franchise
Before still like Logan's slow somber goodbye most fans believe X's ultimate fate was just as perfect for his part Stewart
Seems to agree check out one of our newest videos right here
Plus even more looper videos about your favorite stuff for coming soon subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you